where has he been when will he return
the prophecy foretells of a coming of a
dark age an age when he will be missing
but the prophecy foretells one more
thing
look now closely closely into your own
heart into your own mind into your own
soul and there he is
there he has always been waiting forever
with you inside you a part of you always
oh he was just in the closet the whole
time hello everybody it's me thank you
for welcoming me back I've been away a
couple days it's been spin kid I had a
good time
leave your entry in us really close
that's right we're going to look at more
memes together probably they're all
going to be outdated because it's been a
week means if any memes in this year
surpasses one week lifetime that would
be great that would just be great we're
gonna go through the green screen
competition let's begin
[Music]
well what did I say should I just go
back oh I'll go back another hi I'm
Renata bliss and I'm your freestyle
dance teacher
come on guys I think there's a dead body
there you don't want to next with me
oh it's classic to fighting great
[Music]
Wow
damn that was amazing Wow I could barely
tell it was edited Dan so good Wow nice
to meet you wanna be friends I have an
army of 60 million subscribers beautiful
just great
hey fat oh my god you don't want to mess
with me I have an army of 60 million
subscribers what
I want a full version that was so good
oh my god someone spent hours on this
goddamn god bless you Matt Jones you
burn this up
goddamn follow me oh it's coming out of
my home this way - oh it's a big one
it's a bad thing I love it so much
you're gonna be such a great mother I'm
gonna call him Jack said - yeah
beautiful
my bike got stolen recently somebody
that's I was pretty bummed about it I'm
so shocked and sad but I think whoever
stole it was probably more happy to get
it then I am sad to lose it
the total happiness in the world
increased so whatever I don't know I
don't know what to say Greg
[Applause]
[Music]
hey come on come on have I told you
about this chair by the way have I I
don't know fight my chair and it can do
a lot of things it can do a lot of
things okay
[Music]
whoa
what made you decide to join the
paratroopers when I fight you and seal
all the old me our subscribers
Jesus Easy Company time twice is
property in this regimen
[Music]
I'm just like where am i hey
found one another abundant rain yes
great nor does anybody here know do you
guys I found the way follow me just
Manos de witte show me anyway that's
right impostor you do not know do you
think you're tough oh poor Jax did I
scare you did I scare you little Jackie
boy Jackie boy got scared by a video
game or just scared I would never get
scared by a video game cuz I'm a real
man
oh my testosterone levels your
testosterone levels oh nice to meet you
wanna be friends
hell no yeah oh come on P can you do
this can you just buy my chair please is
399 oh you think you should dude huh you
think you're so good that yeah you think
you're tough huh do you think there's
something special
[Music]
yes
we were like if you are depressed
$3.99 and your depression will be cured
of course yes I'm using mental illness
to sell my chair what you got what
that's not that's not okay I love the
movie edits yeah I know where this is
coming
they review cute that was cute very cute
[Music]
tamatekapua
there's a mood failures my school yeah
Bella holy cow this one got 11,000 of
boats you don't want to mess with me
coz I will fight you my work the way up
to more than you are cutting that's not
true Seto
[Music]
well they say a run faster they like
itself
[Music]
nice power moving right there haha oh
yeah this Alexa what do you do I go
through funny pictures and go that you
guys mean you my guys make the picture
awesome
Alexa play rock music electricity oh
yeah what Alexa what time is it it's
time for bonus we actually don't have to
go
it uses far-field technology so it can
hear you from anywhere in the room
anywhere yes well everyone can hear you
anyway Alexa at wrapping paper to the
shopping list 399 that's a great price
Alexa how many teaspoons are in a
tablespoon no no okay that was the green
screen submissions good job give
yourself a round of applause we're back
with the daily uploads I had a great
time when I was away but I'm very happy
to be back keep making videos did you
miss me leave a like and if you didn't
leave a like also be sure to leave a
like can we get this video on trending
and that's it for me for now see you
tomorrow with a new video and as always
I'm going to go back where I sleep have
a great one
have a great time everybody leave a like
if you're depressed
[Music]